this is the all-new a7 s3 10 bit 422
4k 120 frames a second an all-new sensor
larger pixels for improved low light an
all-new redesigned menu system
incredibly fast autofocus full hdmi
output
and more
hey it's justine and i'm so excited to
be showing you guys today the all-new
sony a7 s3 this is the camera that we've
all been waiting for
and guess what we're shooting on it
right now
[Music]
we have been wandering around the park
i'm not even sure what we filmed but
we've been trying to get a lot of cool
shots but it's so difficult because it
is so incredibly hot out here
you can't last very long out here
without getting some air conditioning
but this place is incredible
[Music]
the a7s3 has an all new processor it's
eight times faster than the previous
gen a7s2 you can shoot up to 10 bit 422
120 frames a second with this new
fastener processor sony is coming out
with some all-new cf cards that will be
able to handle the right speeds of 600
megabits a second you'll need this when
you're shooting in the new 4k snq
setting
there's actually four card slots in this
camera there's two sd and there's two cf
express slots what's great about sq
is you can set the final output of what
the frame rate you want it to be so
say we want to shoot in 120 frames a
second and we want the final output to
be 24 frames a second this will
automatically make that video file for
you and this is great because it saves
so much space because that video is
automatically rendered but there is no
audio
there's a few new 4k options to shoot in
we've mostly been shooting in
4k xavchs which is h265 and it's a much
better compression and this will give us
smaller file sizes compared to xavcs on
previous models what you shooting in 120
yeah
cool oh crispy wait can you do audio in
this
yeah we are right now no way hit the mic
it's on
as long as you're not in snq oh yeah so
in snq it automatically
will turn the clip into whatever frame
rate you want but if you shoot just
120 like this that's cool the really new
and exciting mode though
is 4k xavc-si all intra
in this mode it is shooting every single
frame in the previous modes
it skips a few frames and kind of merges
everything together to make it look
seamless
but this does not skip any frames it
shoots every
single frame to give you the most crisp
and perfect and smooth shots
that you can get this will also give you
a much larger file size so if you're not
worried about storage
or compression then this might be the
mode for you i think a lot of higher end
productions are really gonna love this
feature because it really is giving you
the highest quality that you possibly
can get from this camera this knew what
this looks like and smells like
freaking chucky cheese pizza oh my gosh
it smells like it
this looks i i'm so happy
[Music]
[Applause]
if we want to get really crazy this
camera will actually shoot up to 16 bit
raw using an external recorder
the recorder that we use all the time
for pretty much everything that we shoot
previously on the a7 iii we use the
atomos ninja 5 recorder and this thing's
amazing
just looking at some of the footage that
we shot already on this camera just in
two two ten bit i can't even imagine
what the 16 bit raw is gonna look like
so today we decided to do a really fun
hike to
corona arch do with that what you will
[Music]
let's juggle 120 ready
recording limits have long been an issue
with a lot of these cameras and it's not
just sony cameras a lot of them do have
recording limits mostly because of the
heat issue with this camera there's a
new heat dissipating structure
so that helps the airflow and that also
helps us not have a recording limit when
you're shooting in 24 or 30 frames a
second there is about an hour time limit
if you are shooting in 60 frames a
second in about 30 minutes if you're
shooting in 120 frames a second
if you are recording that long and
higher frame rates what are you doing
this flip-out screen has been so
incredible for things like this because
right now i'm sitting on top of a van
and it's kind of like a very unstable
situation the vlogging community
has been obsessed with having these flip
out screens and for so long sony
for whatever reason has not had the flip
out screen
obviously a lot of people think that
this is just something that vloggers
need
no i have been shooting a lot of nature
stuff so trying to get like low shots
trying to get shots of jenna this thing
has been so helpful
but yeah of course it's also super
helpful to see yourself
i know cute you cute
oh yeah that's cool you know what
dust this is dust resistant
we have improved dust improvement
[Music]
i did a test with all 10 of the built-in
customizable picture profiles
i just used standard default what they
have built in in camera but these are
fully customizable so you can change
them to be whatever you want
s-log 2 and s-log 3 will give you 15
plus stops of dynamic range
being able to shoot 10-bit 422
internally and 16-bit externally raw is
gonna be
so amazing and so much fun to color
grade i can't claim to be the best at
grading but i feel like one of the
things that's fun about this
is we're gonna have so many more options
and so much more range of color to work
with
that'll definitely give you more
flexibility there's also 10 built-in
creative color looks and i don't
ever usually use these but if you do
here's what they all look like
[Music]
so the sun just went down and it's
starting to get dark very quickly
one of the reasons that most people
gravitate towards the a7s series
is because of its low light sensitivity
but with this right now we're shooting
with a 1.8 24 millimeter g master lens
so this is allowing so much more light
in that it probably looks like it's
daylight
sort of no yeah tyler shook his head yes
the base iso is 80 and goes all the way
up to 100 2 400 and from
40 to 409 600 in extended
this shoots 12 megapixels like the
previous a7 s2
but the pixels are much larger on the
new a7s3 allowing much more light per
pixel and i'm so excited because tonight
we're gonna try to get the astro shot
we've tried for the past several nights
the guys went out last night and stayed
up and uh we went the night before
yeah here we go so it's gonna be very
dangerous over here oh that's a drop
it's just drawing it is you can go
around but like i was up there on that
edge
okay um
the perfect night shot is not an easy
task but tonight we're here again
to try to make this happen and this time
we're using this app that our friend
curtis told us about it's called
photopills so it's pretty cool because
you can actually use the phone and it's
like ar
and you can see in what time where the
milky way is going to be so we got the
edelkrone today as well so we're going
to try to set that up
there's a lot it's going to make sense
it's going to look cool ready put it in
one two three
team stars
is the camera are you has your hand okay
it's fine
i can't really say that i was much help
with astro because
i've been sleeping so we probably have
like a five-second time lapse oh my god
but it's cool it's cool
[Music]
low light has always been one of the
main features of the a7s series and with
this that is
no exception i'm out on this trip with
my sister jenna and our friends tyler
and jace
and they are a little bit better at
staying up a little later than i am
because i definitely fell asleep in the
van
several nights that's so cool it's
pretty cool i'm in there
that's amazing safe from all the bugs
guys i'm very proud of you and i'm very
impressed and i'm sorry it's just
sleeping yeah
in body stabilization on this camera is
actually pretty good for a lot of these
shots we were using a lens that doesn't
actually have any stabilization in it so
it was relying fully on the camera
itself
we're using the 24 1.4 g master lens and
it just looks
so crispy they also have two new
stabilization modes so they have an
active steady and they have an active
standard or you can completely turn
those off
if you do choose the active steady this
is giving you a much more stabilized
shot
but it does crop in 10
i'm so excited this is something that i
wanted to check out i was doing some
trail research yesterday and i saw one
that said dinosaur tracks
and petroglyphs and you know what i said
we go there tomorrow and now we're here
[Music]
[Applause]
here it is this is what we came here for
[Music]
the body of the camera is really similar
to a lot of the other sony alpha lines
even when we were shooting these product
shots
i was getting a little confused as to
which camera was which so it does all
kind of come down to the small details
the number one giveaway though is that
flip out screen
it also has a new full hdmi port which i
absolutely love
a lot of times these have the micro or
the mini hdmi ports and these can easily
get bent
or they're not easily accessible there's
been so many times where we've been out
shooting and we do not have
our mini or micro hdmi cables so now we
can just rip a full hdmi out of a tv
and we're good to go the input and
output audio are directly next to each
other and it has an all new
electronic viewfinder i typically don't
ever use the viewfinder because most of
the times i'm either shooting myself
or i can have an external monitor that i
can look at but we've been using it so
much out on this shoot because it's so
bright
that being able to have that new
electronic viewfinder everything looks
so crisp i also love having the
touchscreen be touched to focus
and the autofocus on this thing is so
freaking fast
one of the reasons that i had to upgrade
my a7s ii to the a7 iii
is the focus on the a7 ii and this is
not new information to anyone who has
had one
is a little bit slow they also redid the
strap holders so a lot of times when
people would be filming with these
cameras you would hear these things
dangling around
but they made them really stiff so they
don't actually move at all
i also love that this has a usbc port so
you can use this for transferring data
but you can also use it to power the
camera one thing that i really like
about this camera is especially for us
we're usually vlogging and kind of doing
handheld shots very quickly and moving
the camera around and with the a7s 3 it
minimizes the rolling shutter
significantly
so in this demo you guys can see the
rolling shutter difference now what
you're looking for is the distortion of
the image
so the new a7s3 as you can see here has
a very clear image and nothing is
getting distorted
where the other it looks a little wavy
this camera is something that a lot of
people have been waiting very very
patiently for and i'm so glad that we
finally have all of the details and i'm
so glad i actually got a chance to take
a look at this for you guys
and i can promise you you're not going
to be disappointed a huge thank you to
sony for sending me my sister out here
with a review unit to be able to check
out and share our experience with you if
you guys enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel because i'll be
definitely doing a follow-up on this
camera when i actually get one for
myself
i have been loving it so much and i just
cannot wait until september
i'll see you guys in the next video bye
do you remember what we did yesterday
no when we rented a little tiny car and
got stuck in a rainstorm and there was
lightning and thunder and then
we drove all the way back and had to
return the car early only to find out
that the car had a flat tire so if we
would have continued going out
we probably would have been stranded oh
that that
and then also i was filming an sq which
doesn't have audio because we were
testing that out
so all the stuff that i was talking
about telling you about the flat tire
we didn't get the audio but the sq
footage looks really cool
then we went to the grocery store and i
bought a little jacket for my yerba mate
and a hacky sack
oh
make sure we don't forget to get the
sack before we leave we will
you